they're husband-and-wife team it just
happens to both be Academy
award-nominated they're both in the
movie crystal that's in theaters near
you a week from tomorrow the director
William H may see also in the film with
Felicity Huffman you're together it's
fun I think it's the first time we've
been on a talk show together so yeah I
think losing our charity through what
what you're losing your yeah well you
did say that ll it's it's it's
absolutely fine because you know no is
this a first for us to husband-and-wife
team you better lie that's all I can say
my wife has sat in this chair when I'm
out of it she's a fill-in host for the
show so that's the husband and wife
combination it's just in one chair not
not two like this all right so you guys
how many times have you guys worked
together then a lot but we we try to
make it special when we do it I mean we
try to make sure it's the right project
so that it remains special and this one
was it just seemed perfect and it's the
I do say so it's my favorite part of the
film I gotta say when Felicity came down
you could just feel the whole thing rise
up a little bit she came down she was
prepared and she jumped right into it
and it was a shot of adrenaline for
everyone
that's so sweet he likes me I love ya
I'm really touched by this whole thing
that's pretty cool so uh you know
Felicity you you were in sports night
yeah back in the day producer of
essentially the Sports Center you were
that I was doing at the time yeah Erin
came and interviewed you right yeah he
did him we gave him some ideas that
actually did wind up in the show how
come you can't how come you never came
to Bristol Connecticut to kick the time
I know nothing about sports I mean no
Aaron said that a sport tonight was
about sports the way Charlie's Angels is
about law enforcement and I fit right
into that I I know nothing about
anything about sports oh that's not a
source not on in your house and never
once have you ever what
the last sporting event you've been to
Felicity I went to a basketball game
okay which one was this who's in LA
here in LA yeah Lakers yes the Lakers
they were very tall okay they're very
tall they had a ball okay and speakers
and they scored sorry and I yes they
scored no which is as much as I did
that's and I was on the you know I was
on the good seats on the floor now you
have to be careful cuz if you extend
your legs a little bit too far you might
actually trip one of these guys I know
what's it like I think a Curb Your
Enthusiasm type moment Rick Fox is in
this film right Rick Fox is in Crystal
and he's very funny so how did Rick Fox
get hooked up with this film Rick did
about two shows on shameless this TV
show that I'm on and subdued he and I
pretended to snort two pounds of cocaine
if my memory serves that that was the
thing you sure this wasn't we had the
best time I mean it's sort of it's sort
of you have to finish this story fast
because if it's Rick Fox you're talking
about having fun snorting cocaine well
even though it's fake white powder and
you're just pretending there's something
about it it's Pavlovian and we just had
the best time right also acting wise
there's no wrong you can do anything you
jolly well please cuz you're supposed to
be just blasted out of your mind on coke
right anyway I had the best time with
him
and he was perfect for this role and I
called him up and I said well you do it
and he said Yeah right
my favorite kind of interaction with an
actor they just say yes and he just came
on and he did he's got the chops he's
got the acting chops
oh yeah he's really good and he stupidly
good-looking and that was important for
this role and he's smart and fast and
he's got he's got that he can play an
audience he really he knows his stuff
that's right and so when it all comes
down to it William H Macy and Felicity
Huffman here on the Rich Eisen show
working together how does that work when
you guys are off set
how does that work Felicity you want to
handle that one or does that work you
mean talking about the biz when
so yeah we do it yeah we do it below he
says you know when I'm sober I'm really
professional we we've worked together
our whole lives I think we worked
together before we were a couple so what
did you first meet that in that regard
we met in the theater in New York the
Atlantic Theatre Company and still
exists it's one of the best dog broth
off-broadway houses there and we were
both members so was Mamet cupid for you
guys yeah I guess he was actually a guy
named Scott Ziegler was really Cupid for
us okay and we had one rule and I think
we've pretty much stuck to that which is
we don't talk about it literally in bed
so because we talk shop a lot so if
we're on a project and we're lying down
someone goes I have an idea you both
have to stand up and right so that's a
hard and fast rule for something like
that it's not a good idea I think for
people who are in the same business to
talk about it at home but for some
reason that's our that's what we're all
about we we met each other talking about
this stuff and we both like love acting
and showbiz in the same way so it works
for us it works great I'll say you act
with someone like Bill and it raises the
level of your game I have to say you
know good actors I guess good athletes
are the same way yes they are I see I
said something about a that you do you
think you'd I mean you actually said
something that was spot-on
did you never play yeah yeah I love
sports that play a lot of sports okay so
which ones do you play I ski raced I
play tennis I play softball and and
soccer all through high school and into
college okay where'd you go to school
uh-oh why you and why you hmm yeah I'm
just going to they don't have much of a
sports program they're not very much at
all she's a magnificent skier though
okay that's really fundamental works out
William H Macy and Felicity Huffman here
on the Rich Eisen show we have something
that called start bench cut mm-hmm that
we like to play here where you I gave
you a choice of three and then you go
ahead and have to choose which one you
start bench meaning you know it doesn't
start but it's something that's still on
your team and still on the team and cut
is it's not we know we're in our
business we say
go a different direction okay all right
so here we go let's play we're just just
honor to be nominated really and blah
blah okay this one's for you William
okay the best Felicity Huffman
performance Desperate Housewives
american crime Transamerica for which
felicity was nominated for an Oscar oh I
just got the perfidy of this little game
I get to say that I would play
Transamerica in a New York minute but
now I got a cut one of your yes things
you know what I I would change the rules
in play all three so there yeah okay cut
housewives except it paid for everything
okay cut Transamerica it paid for
nothing okay see that's what it's all
it's all about the yeah the Benjamins
correct in that regard and that you'd
start what then American crime you'd
start start American crime until they go
very good all right this one's for you
then Felicity best William H Macy
performance Fargo the cooler Boogie
Nights start bench [ __ ] I would start
with the cooler I would bench Fargo and
I would cut Boogie Nights why are you
cutting Boogie Nights you made up the
rules okay thank God we're not our own
agents let's do two more here
favorite Chicago sports icon William
like Walter Payton Michael Jordan Harry
Carey start bench cut okay I'd start
Walter I did a commercial with him one
time really cool guy what commercial did
you do with him
Oh God Only Knows a car company a car
company maybe our car
come on a local thing Jerry did Jerry
Lundegaard do that commercial no Walter
Payton did now is the other that was the
little kid he was saying stupid things
okay okay and I would okay what would
the three again its Walter Payton
Michael Jordan Harry Carey
so you're started you're starting Walter
now do you bench Michael or no you got
to put Michael on the bench Harry I love
you like a brother did you ever meet him
no I never did what a great guy though I
met him one time I was at a in grad
school at Northwestern Medill School of
Journalism huh
they were naming Tom trouble or in the
new manager of the Chicago Cubs in 1994
they had a noon press conference I
showed up at 10:00 a.m. just to be early
because I was a college kid he was
already three bloody marys into the dirt
getting he was funny I was a Cubs fan I
lived on Sheffield so you know they
killed out tickets for day of the game
and I spent a lot of time and did a lot
of damage to my liver I bet you did cuz
Harry did too all right last one for you
Felicity things you'd rather do with
William H Macy be directed by him act
with him dance with him Wow
start bench cot start bench cut I would
say I would like to act with him start I
would like to be directed by him I mean
I'd have to cut Dancing with you I'm
sorry darling
oh I would have to chose well dancing
with you we were gonna go singing you
guys do karaoke ever actually you can
sing what what is what you go to karaoke
William no no he plays he writes songs
on as you go okay on your ukulele
ukulele man look you can save the world
so uh just let's talk before I let you
guys go about Crystal and theaters near
you again on April 13th a week from
tomorrow well what did you enjoy most
about this felicity well I loved being
directed by Bill I loved acting with him
but I also think it's just such a great
ensemble
it's rosario Dawson and Nick
Robinson and Kathy Bates TI's in this
yeah yeah isn't it he's so funny god
they're just wonderful actors all in it
so every time I showed up on set no
matter who I was acting with I I have a
very small part it was just a thrill to
watch all these people act and also I
think it's great to have a sweet hopeful
movie in these times and that's what it
is it's a literary piece it's very smart
there are seven or eight major
characters and they all have a plot
beginning middle and end and it was
really difficult story to tell it was so
sophisticated and complex I liked the
challenge it's my kind of movie so it's
I mean you say it's complex when it's a
teenage kid with a heart ailment yeah
who goes to AAA because he's trying to
hit on a stripper who has all sorts of
drug problems it's it's a family comedy
on top yeah that's what you mean by
confusing and difficult and it's one of
those weird things that is very complex
and but the result is simple it looks
like a simple story when you watch it
but the pieces are myriad and there it
was it was a it was a tough get to
figure out how to do this thing well I
appreciate you guys coming in here hey
thanks for coming up Sarah I'm a big fan
of both of yours back at you thank you
very much you got it Felicity Huffman
and William H may see here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience